les rives paisibles du Nièvre dans une
capitale ukrainienne où la vie suit son
cours malgré la guerre
sauf que les bateaux de plaisance sont
disparus
il y a toujours beaucoup de bateaux de
catamaran de kayak mais depuis
l'invasion à grande échelle la
navigation est interdite aussi civile
ici désormais seuls les navires
militaires patrouille
les drones kamikaze lancé par la Russie
vole le long d'une Nièvre un passage
altitude quand il tente d'attaquer la
capitale ukrainienne alors ces
patrouilles fluviales sont une partie
importante des défenses antérieures de
kievous
un pasteltitude
ce qui les rend presque invisibles
sont impuissants l'oeil humain peut
servir
visuellement ou bien on les entend au
bruit et alors on les abats mais je n'ai
pas le droit de vous dire comment on le
fait
prier 2022 Anton était capitaine sur un
navire marchand
comme pour tant d'autres la guerre a
changé sa vie
le premier jour où l'Ukraine a été
attaqué j'ai fait ma demande de
rapatriement je crois que j'étais alors
en Inde mais le navire faisait route
vers la Chine et je ne pouvais pas le
quitter à cause du coronavirus alors
j'ai dû attendre environ un mois et demi
s'imposait les bateaux qu'il pilotent
aujourd'hui sont bien plus petit que ces
anciens navires de commerce mais la
cause est grande